hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome tell
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer question from one of my
newsletter readers stop even wrote in
asking if you don't mind me asking what
kind of companies do you own and what
inspires you so thanks for the question
my main business is my website so 7
chronicle com were one of the largest
websites for entrepreneurs if you're
looking for inspiration advice to grow
your business I started the company
around famous entrepreneur advice when I
was young I was 19 I had my first real
business I didn't know what I was doing
I was scared it was a software company
and I then thought to myself you know
I'm not the first person and trying to
sell software before and I looked at
famous entrepreneurs who had success in
the software field guys like Bill Gates
guys like the people behind into it and
mcafee and I looked at their success and
saw they started from nothing and they
were able to build a huge business and I
was looking at how do they make their
first million you know I don't care how
Bill Gates makes his extra million now
but how did it go from zero to that
first million and that those stories
inspired me and helped me build my
business at the point where we were to
build it to customers in 30 countries
and we got acquired and i started my
website as a way to give back to other
entrepreneurs and share those stories of
famous entrepreneur so we have one of
the largest collections of famous
entrepreneur stories and you are online
and one of my favorite bits of advice
for entrepreneurs is if you're trying to
accomplish something look at somebody
who's already done what you're trying to
do and model their success it'll help
shortcut your path to success and keep
you inspired I really found that reading
those famous entrepreneurs stories got
me inspired got me motivated to see that
you know they had all these challenges
growing up and making their business get
to that next step but also it gave me
specific strategies that I used
implement to my business so my main
business is my website we've got tons of
articles on there hopefully some ideas
and resources to to help you grow your
business and motivate you to keep going
and our business model is selling
advertising and also partnering up with
corporations who are trying to reach
into the small business community so we
do a lot of work with telus as an
example and other companies and provide
value-added content for them I create
blog posts and you may have seen some of
the posts that I've done if you're a fan
of the youtube channel so that's my main
business in terms of what inspires me I
really like helping the little guy I
love the come-from-behind stories i love
the rags-to-riches stories one of my
favorite movies is Seabiscuit which is a
movie about a horse that everybody you
know ruled out thought was going to be
too small and would never be a
successful racer and went on to be a
really successful racer so I love those
stories and that's why i love
entrepreneurship because a lot of times
it's the little guy trying to take on
the big companies and nobody gives them
a chance and you're battling against all
odds and you put it in crazy hours and
you don't know if it's going to work or
not and and hopefully you come out on
the other side so i love those stories
if whenever i see somebody who's had
that success if it's within the
entrepreneur circle or or any field if
you look at the top people in any
industry any endeavor of sports or
whatever it is you'll usually find that
they had to overcome a lot of hardship
to get to where they are and reading
those stores interviewing those people
gets me inspired makes you want to do
more makes me want to help more people
as well so i tend to focus on the
Entrepreneurship world we have all these
profiles of famous entrepreneurs and I
find reading those help me stay
motivated and inspired and reading their
quotes and seeing how they came from
nothing that keeps me going every day
and also the the feedback from you guys
I love making these videos I'm right now
sending to my house talking to a camera
but what what gets you motivated is seen
the comments come in and seen the likes
come in and people saying how these
videos help them with their business and
change their lives and so that inspires
me every day to want to get up and keep
doing more to help out entrepreneurs so
thanks for the question hopefully that
helped answer it I it for those are you
watching again if you want to give it a
thumbs up below please do makes me want
to do more of these videos and if you
have a comment or question please leave
it in the comment section but
I always read those and hopefully I'll
be able to answer your questions if you
want to leave one below so thank you i
will see you on the next episode
I